رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
استووا اعتدلوادر
حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج
ولا تختلفوا فتختلف قلوبكم
الله
اكبر
اعوذ بالله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين
والى مدين اخاهم شعيبا
قال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله
غيره قد جاءتكم
بينه من ربكم
فاوف فوا الكيل والميزان ولا تبخسوا الناس
اشياءهم
ولا تفسدوا في الارض بعد اصلاحها
ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم مؤمنين
ولا تقعدوا بكل صراط توعدون وتصدون عن
سبيل الله
وتصدون عن سبيل الله من امن به وتبغونها
عوجا
واذكروا اذ كنتم قليلا فكثركم
وانظروا كيف كان عاقبه المفسدين
وان كان طائفه
منكم امنوا بالذي ارسلت به وطا طائفه
وطائفه
لم يؤمنوا فاصبروا حتى يحكم الله بيننا
وهو خير الحاكمين
قال الملا الذين استكبروا من قومه لنخرجنك
يا شعيب والذين امنوا معك والذين امنوا
معك من قريتنا او لتعودن
في ملتنا
قال اولو كنا كارهين
قد افترينا على الله كذبا ان عدنا في
ملتكم
بعد اذ نجانا الله منها وما يكون لنا ان
نعود فيها الا ان يشاء الله ربنا
وسع ربنا
كل شيء علما
على الله توكلنا
ربنا افتح بيننا وبين قومنا بالحق وانت
خير الفاتحين
وقال الملا الذين كفروا من قومه لئن
اتبعتم شعيبا انكم اذا لخاسرون
فاخذتهم الرجف ه فاصبحوا في دارهم جاثمين
الذين كذبوا شعيبا كان لم يغنوا فيها
الذين كذبوا شعيبا كانوا هم الخاسرين
فتولى عنهم وقال يا قوم لقد ابلغتكم
رسالات ربي ونصحت لكم فكيف كيف اسى على
قوم كافرين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
رب اغفر لي وارحمني واجبرني
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وما ارسلنا في قريه من نبي الا اخذنا
اهلها بالباساء
والضراء
الا اخذنا اهلها بالباساء
لعلهم يضرعون
ثم بدلنا مكان السيئه الحسنه حتى عفوا
وقالوا قد مس اباءنا
الضراء
والسراء
فاخذناهم
بغته وهم لا يشعرون
ولو ان اهل القرى امنوا واتقوا لفتحنا
عليهم بركات من السماء السماء
والارض
ولكن كذبوا فاخذناهم
بما كانوا يكسبون
افامن اهل القرى ان ياتيهم
باسنا بياتا وهم نائمون
اومن اهل القرى ان ياتيهم باسنا ضحا وهم
يلعب
افامنوا مكر الله
فلا يامن مكر الله الا القوم الخاسرون
اولم يهد للذين يرثون الارض من بعد اهلها
ان لو يشاء ان لو نشاء
اصدناهم
بذنوبهم
ونطبع على قلوب بهم فهم لا يسمعون
تلك القرى نقص عليك من انبائها
ولقد جاءتهم
رسلهم بالبينات فما كانوا ليؤمنوا
فما كانوا ليؤمنوا بما كذبوا من قبل كذلك
يطبع الله على قلوب بالكافرين
وما وجدنا لاكثرهم
من عهد وان وجدنا اكثرهم لفاسقين
ثم بعثنا من بعدهم موسى باياتنا
الى فرعون وملائه فظلموا بها فانظر كيف
كان عاقبه المفسدين
وقال موسى يا فرعون اني رسول من رب
العالمين
حقيق على الا اقول على الله الا الحق قد
جئتكم ببينه
من ربكم فارسل معي بني اسرائيل
قال فرعون
قال ان كنت جئت بايه فات بها ان كنت من
الصادقين
فالقى عصاه فاذا هي ثعبان مبين
ونزع يده فاذا هي بيضاء
للناظرين
قال الملا من فرعون قال الملا من قوم
فرعون ان هذا لساحر عليم
يريد ان يخرجكم من ارضكم فماذا تامرون
قالواجه واخاه وارسل في المدائن
حاشرين
ياتوك بكل ساحر عليم
وجاء
السحره فرع فرعون قالوا ان لنا لاجرا ان
كنا نحن الغالبين
قال نعم وانكم لمن المقربين
قالوا يا موسى اما ان تلقي واما ان نكون
نحن الملقين
قال القوا فلما
القوا سحروا اعين
الناس واسترهبوهم
سحروا اعين الناس واسترهبوهم
وجاؤوا
بسحر عظيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
والصلوات والطيبات السلام عليك
السلام علينا وعلى الصالحين اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط المستقيم الصراط الذين انعمت
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
نستعين الصراط المستقيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
رب اغفر لي وارحمني واجبرني وفعني واهدني
واعف
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله
[Arabic recitation]
‏just want to share with you cle of
things and cle of request first
this frid be the funding for the academy
and as you know this is only sch that
serving the greater are for muslম kids
so we need your gener
to make it happ so more tomrow
நசல்
[Silence]
கன் இஹ
மங்
காசெ
இஹபக்அஆர்பலிபல
இ பாங்லய
இ pleas
‏and
as you can
reon me to say that we have some
improvement in the par
which has created some additional
dust
that is and if you are not driving slow
going to kick in the air and that is
additional pollution so we want to make
sure we don't disturb that dirt
পার্
আহমদ
প্রশ্ন
মসজিদ ইনশল্লাহর
পারিং কস
‏have to make we keep managing it as
best as we can last but not least as you
know the wednesday is one of the service
days for our ne
park in their par
as a princile
and when they clear obly we can use it
but better if we just refrain from the
using paring lot on the service days
that they have told us سو جزاكم الله
خيرا السلام عليكم
جزاك الله خيرا
[Arabic recitation]
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه
وخليله وامينه على وحيه يداعي الى رضوانه
فاللهم صل وسلم وبارك بارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
سوره الاعراف
number
two
are very
صلى الله عليه وسلم سراف
‏era
andat
years
before and that's why hij and
you know that part of the story of musa
عليه السلام is fixated on in this
chapter in الاعراف because it was
preparing
صلى الله عليه وسلمجره
سوره الانفال
ان شاء الله
غزوه بدر the
الله
غزوه بدر
رمضان
سوره الاعراف
‏boil down to one main theme
and one main narrative
a very long
but the chapter and every
and every story that is in it every isue
that is mentioned
it is all
سراف
‏end of empires
empires that the most powerful of their
day
that for the people living in those
empires believed could never come to an
end they couldn't even imagine the earth
without these empires.
‏Right now, all of us, could we imagine
Earth today without America? Is it
possible for us to imagine that world?
We've been born into its era of America.
But every single human being and every
single collection of human being and
every human endeavor will all come to
endentually.
‏And what marks the end of every empire
is their
devolvement into
decadence
and wickedness and moral depravity.
This is the beginning of the end.
‏We can almost if you could imagine with
me a graph
and you were to imagine technology down
here is where it starts and people's
moralitys high
as people become more comfortable and
technologically advanced their moralys
to go down as their techny rises this
isn't technology is evil
ما لم يعلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قليل من عباده الشكور
thanful
‏as skyets and com and when they are
very height of their comبحes
exactly سيساز وما ارسلنا في قريه من نبي
الا اخذنا اهلها بالباساء والضراء الباساء
يعني الامراض او الباساء بمعنى الفقر
والضراء الامراض لعلهم يتضرعون يعني تتفتح
قلوبهم الى قبول رساله الرسل
‏any
people
ثم ثم بدلنا مكان السيئه الحسنه حتى عفوا
عفوا يعني كثروا
وماذا يقولون عن تاريخهم؟
وقالوا قد مس ابائنا الضراء والسراء. هذه
الايام الدنيا هيك يوم عسل ويوم بصل يوم
طالع ويوم نازل شيء عادي ما هو له دخل لا
بالله ولا رسل ولا شيء من هذا القبيل
فاخذناهم بغته وهم لا يشعرون
that
is
takes
الله سبحانه وتالى makes
huge empire
about hisory
look ourul
just ‏everybody else good times and
bad times that has nothing to do with
God doesn't have anything to do with
messengers it's not a punishment from
God these are natural things that just
happen to everyone there nothing special
about this
and at that moment is الله سبحانه وتالى
takes them
we will end with a very quick summary of
this Allah mentions just before this
statement
[Silence]
‏people
‏their
kind of if you think about the mega
mega corations
where they want to sell you something
they tell you look we just care about
your health that's why we're in this
business we're in this business because
we care deeply about our customers sure
as they poison us and give us cancers
and give they tell us this in the same
time the people of media were exactly
like
الله سبحانه وتالى
was
still
there wasn't even
a little tiny gust of wind anywh it was
sitting in oven they sit in their
houseot they come outside they
‏and
days
one of them spot a cloud that came out
and this cloud settled at the outirts of
their city of Medan and so this person
went out there under this cloud and
found it to be so cool and comforting
‏was suddenly being in the most
blissful cool. And so one by one they
started to call each other out to under
this cloud and they all accumulated
under this cloud and Allah
tells us in
Hud that they were taken by
the day of the cloud the day of the
great cloud. ‏What is the day of the
great cloud? Well, they were all
gathered under this cloud and they were
in bliss. Was so cool and comfortable
after this baking hot. And then the
cloud rained fire on them and it
destroyed every last person of Medan.
‏And every single one of these
empires that we listen to last night and
tonight, every one of them thought the
exact same thing that we think today.
No, we're too big to fail. The world
can't go on without us. Our empire is to
important to critical, impossible.
‏could
fa
سوره الاعراف نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان
ينفعنا بما علمنا نساله سبحانه وتعالى الا
يؤاخذنا بما فعل السفهاء منا والله اعلم
صلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
[Silence]
استقيم واعتديستو
سو الصوص والخلل
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد اوحينا
الى موسى ان الق عصاك فاذا هي تلقف ما
يافكون
فوقع الحق وبطل ما كانوا يعملون
فغلبوا هنالك وانقلبوا صاغرين
والقي السحره ساجدين
قالوا امنا برب العالمين
رب موسى وهارون
قال فرعون امنتم
به قبل ان اذن لكم ان هذا لمكر مكرتموه في
المدينه لتخرجوا
لتخرجوا منها اهلها فسوف تعلمون
لاقطعن
ايديكم وارجلكم من خلاف
ثم
لاصلبنكم
اجمعين
قالوا انا الى ربنا منقلبون
وما تنقمنا
الا ان امنا
بايات ربنا لما جاءتنا
ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا
وتوفنا مسلمين
وقال الملا من قوم فرعون اتذر موسى وقومه
في الارض
اتذر موسى وقومه في الارض ليذرك والهتك
ليفسدوا في الارض ويذرك والهتك
قال سنقتل ابناءهم
قال سنقتل ل ابناءهم
ونستحيي نساءهم
وانا
فوقهم قاهرون
قال موسى لقومه استعينوا بالله واصبروا
ان الارض لله يورثها من يشاء
من عباده
والعاقبه للمتقين
قالوا اوذينا من قبل ان تاتينا ومن بعد ما
جئتنا
قال عسى ربكم ان يهلك عدوكم ويستخلفكم
في الارض ويستخلفكم
في الارض فينظر كيف تعملون
ولقد اخذنا ال فرعون بالسنين ونق بالسنين
ولقد اخذنا ال فرعون بالسنين
بالسنين ونقص
من الثمرات لعلهم يذكرون
فاذا جاءتهم
الحسنه قالوا لنا هذه
وان تصبهم سيئه
يطيروا بموسى
من معه الا انما طائركم
عند الله
الا انما طائرهم
عند الله ولكن اكثرهم لا يعلمون
وقالوا مهما تاتنا به من ايه لتسحرنا بها
فما نحن لك المؤمنين
فارسلنا عليهم الطوفان والجراد والقمل
والضفادع والدم ايات مفصلات
فاستكبروا وكانوا قوما مجرمين
ولما
وقع عليهم الرجز قالوا يا موسى
قالوا يا موسى ادع لنا ربك بما عهد عندك
لئن كشفت ع الرجز لنؤمنن
لك لنؤمنن
لك ولنرسلن
معك بني اسرائيل
فلما كشفنا عنهم الرجز الى اجل هم بالغوه
اذا هم ين ينكثون
فانتقمنا
منهم فاغرقناهم
في اليم
بانهم ذلك بانهم
كذبوا باياتنا
وكانوا عنها غافلين
واورثنا القوم الذين كانوا يستضعفون
واورثنا القوم الذين استضعفوا
مشارق الارض ومغاربها
واورثنا القوم الذين كانوا يستضعفون
مشارق الارض ومغاربها التي باركنا فيها
وتمت
كلمه ربك الحسنى على بني اسرائيل
بما صبروا
ودمرنا
ما كان يصنع فرعون وقومه وما كانوا يعرشون
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضال ضالين
امين
وجاوزنا ببني اسرائيل
البحر فاتوا على قوم يعكف يعكفون على
اصنام لهم قالوا يا موسى اجعل لنا الها
كما لهم الهه
قال انكم قوم تجهلون
ان هؤلاء
متبر
ما هم فيه وباطل ما كانوا يعملون
قال غير الله ابغيكم الها وهو فضلكم على
العالمين
واذ انجيناكم
من ال فرعون يسوءكم
سوء العذاب
يسوءكم سوء العذاب يقتلون ابناءكم
ويستحيون
نساءكم
وفي ذلكم بلاء
من ربكم عظيم واذ واعدنا موسى ثلاثين ليله
اتممناها بعشر
وواعدنا موسى ثلاثين ليله واتممناها بعشر
فتم ميقات ربه وقال موسى لاخيه هارون
اخلفني في قومي واصلح واصلح ولا تتبع سبيل
المفسدين
فتم ميقات ربه اربع
ليله
وقال موسى لاخيه هارون اخلفني في قومي
واصلح ولا تتبع سبيل المفسدين
ولما جاء موسى لميقاتنا
وكلمه ربه قال رب ارني انظر اليك قال لن
تراني ولكن انظر الى الجبل فان استقر
مكانه فان استقر مكانه فسوف تراني
فلما تجلى ربه للجبل جعله دكا
وخر موسى صعقا فلما
افاق قال سبحانك
قال سبحانك تبت اليك وانا اول المؤمنين
قال يا موسى اني اصطفيتك على الناس
برسالاتي
وبكلامي
فخذ ما اتيتك وكن من الشاكرين
وكتبنا له في الالواح من كل شيء موعظه
وتفصيلا
لكل شيء فخذها بقوه وامر قومك ياخذوا
باحسنها
ساريكم دار الفاسقين
ساصرف عن اياتي الذين يتكبرون في الارض
بغير الحق وان يروا كل ايه لا يؤمنوا بها
وان يروا سبيل الرشد لا يتخذوه سبيلا
وان يروا سبيل الغي يتخذوه سبيلا
ذلك بانهم كذبوا باياتنا
وكانوا عنها غافلين
والذين كذبوا باياتنا
ولقاء
الاخره حبطت اعم اعمالهم
هل يجزون الا ما كانوا يعملون
واتخذ قوم موسى من بعده من حليهم عجلا
جسدا له خوار
الم يروا انه لا يكلمهم ولا يهديهم سبيلا
اتخذوه وكانوا ظالمين
ولما
سقط في ايديهم وراوا انهم قد ضلوا
قالوا لئن لم يرحمنا ربنا ويغفر لنا
لنكونن
من الخاسرين
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولما رجع موسى الى قومه غضبان ناسيفا
قال بئس ما خلفتموني من بعدي اعجب تم امر
ربكم
والقى الالواح واخذ براس اخيه يجره اليه
قال ابن ام ان القوم استضعفوني وكادوا
يقتلونني
فلا تشمت بي الاعداء
ولا تجعلني مع القوم الظالمين
قال رب اغفر لي ولاخي وادخلنا برحمتك
وادخلنا برحمتك وانت
ارحم الراحمين
وادخلنا في رحمتك وانت ارحم الراحمين
ان الذين اتخذوا العجل سينالهم غضب من
ربهم وذله وذله في الحياه الدنيا وكذ ذلك
نجزي المفترين
والذين عملوا السيئات ثم تابوا من بعدها
واصلحوا
ثم تابوا من بعدها وامنوا ان ربك من بعدها
لغفور رحيم
واختار موسى قومه سبعين رجلا لميقاتنا
ولما سكت عن موسى الغضب اخذ الالواح وفي
نسختها هدى
ورحمه
وفي نسختها هدى ورحمه للذين هم لربهم
يرهبون
واختار موسى قومه سبعين رجلا لميقاتنا
فلما لما اخذتهم الرجفه قال رب لو شئت
اهلكتهم واياي من قبل قال رب لو شئتلكتهم
من قبل واياي
اتهلكنا بما فعل السفهاء
منا
ان هي فتنتك تضل بها من تشاء
وته تهدي من تشاء
انت ولينا فاغفر لنا وارحمنا وانت خير
الغافرين
ان هي الا فتنتك تضل بها من تشاء
وتهدي من تشاء
انت ولينا فاغفر لنا وارحمنا
وارحمنا وانت خير الغافرين
واكتب لنا في هذه الدنيا حسنه
وفي الاخره انا هدنا اليك قال عذابي اصيب
به من اشاء
ورحمتي وسعت كل شيء
فساكتبها للذين يتقون ويؤتون الزكاه
والذين هم باياتنا يؤمنون
الذين يتبعون الرسول النبي الامي الذي
يجدونه مكتوبا عندهم في التوراه والانجيل
يامرهم
يامرهم بالمعروف وينهاهم عن المنكر ويحل
لهم الطيبات
ويحل لهم الطيبات ويحرم عليهم الخبائث
ويضع عنهم اصرهم والاغلال التي كانت عليهم
فالذين امنوا به واتبعوه
فالذين امنوا به وعزروه
ونصروه واتبعوا النور الذي انزل معه اولئك
اولئك
هم المفلحون
قل يا ايها الناس اني رسول الله اليكم
جميعا
فامنوا بالله ورسله
فامنوا بالله ورسولهن
النبي الامي الذي يؤمن بالله
الذي يؤمن بالله وكلماته
فامنوا بالله ورسول فامنوا بالله الذي له
ملك السماوات والارض لا اله الا هو يحيي
ويميت
لا اله الا هو يحيي ويميت
فامنوا بالله ورسوله
النبي الامي الذي يؤمن بالله وكلماته
وكلماته
لعلكم تهتدون
ومن قوم موسى امه
يهدون بالحق
يهدون بالحق وبه يعدلون
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضال الين
امين
وقطعناهم اثنتي عشره اسباطا امما واوحينا
الى موسى اذ استسقاه قومه ان اضرب بعصاك
الحجر
ان اضرب بعصاك الحجر فانبجست منه اثنتا
عشره عينا قد علم كل اناس مشربهم
وظللنا عليهم الغمام وانزلنا
عليهم المن والسلوى
كلوا من طيبات ما رزقناكم
وما ظلمونا ولكن كانوا انفسهم يظلمون
واذ قيل اسكنوا هذه القريه وكلوا منها حيث
شئتم وكلوا منها حيث شئتم وقولوا حطه نغفر
لكم خطيئاتكم
سنزيد المحسنين
واذ قيل لهم اسكنوا هذه القريه وكلوا منها
حيث شئتم وقولوا حطه وقولوا حطه وادخلوا
الباب سجدا
نغفر لكم خطيئاتكم
سنزيد المحسنين
فبدل الذين ظلموا منهم قولا غير الذي قيل
لهم فارسلنا عليهم رجزا من السماء
بما كانوا يظلمون
واسالهم عن القريه التي كانت حاضره البحر
اذ يعدون في السبت اذ تاتيهم حيتانهم
اذ تاتيهم حيتانهم يوم سبتهم شرعا
ويوم لا يثبتون لا تاتيهم
كذلك بلوغناهم
بما كانوا يفسقون
واذ قالت امه منهم لم تعظون قوما الله
مهلكهم او معذبهم عذابا شديدا
قالوا معذره الى ربكم ولعلهم يتقون
فلما نسوا ما ذكروا به اخذناه
اخذنا الذين اخذنا
فلما نسوا ما ذكروا بها اخذنا الذي فلما
نسوا ما ذكروا به اخذنا الذين ينهون
انجينا الذين ينهون عن الفساد واخذنا
الذين ظلموا
واخذنا الذين ظلموا بعذاب بئيس بما كانوا
يفسقون
فلما عتوا عالهوا
عنه قلنا لهم
قلنا لهم كونوا قرده خاسئين
واذ تاذن ربك ليبعثن
عليهم الى يوم القيامه من يسومهم سوء
العذاب
ان ربك لسريع العقاب وانه لغفور
رحيم
وقطعناهم في الارض امما منهم الصالحون
ومنهم دون ذلك وبلوناهم
بالحسنات والسيئات لعلهم يرجعون
فخلف خلف فخلف من بعدهم خلف ورثوا الكتاب
ياخذون عرض هذا الادنى ويقولون
ويقولون سيغفر لنا وان ياتهم عرض مثله
ياخذوه
الم يؤخذ عليهم ميثاق الكتاب الا يقولوا
على الله الا الحق ودرسوا ما فيه والدار
الاخره خير للذين يتقون افلا تعقلون
والذين يمسكون بالكتاب واقاموا الصلاه
انا
لا نضيع اجر المصلحين
[Arabic recitation]
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
العراطلك
العرايه
كل واحد يبقى ليه
[Arabic recitation]
قالتقال
انت
لا تعالى
[Silence]
سبحان
70%
[Silence]
عشان
السلام عليكم اوكي ان شاء الله
تراويح
ركعه
‏eyes
goj and comes back upy him of allerday
we some
in the back the whole first two for like
20 minutes they were just chatting
away it is here please if youve got
a conversation
we got a
‏paring out you could
blue in face if here you this is
this is trying to
استووادلوا استووا
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
واذ نتقنا الجبل فوقهم كانه ظله وظنوا انه
واقع بهم خذوا ما اتيناكم بقوه واذكروا ما
فيه لعلكم تتقون
واذ اخذ ربك بني ادم من ظهورهم ذريتهم
واشهدهم على انفسهم الست بربكم
قالوا بلى شهدنا ان تقولوا يوم القيامه
انا كنا عن هذا غافلين
او تقولوا انما اشرك اباؤنا
من قبل وكنا ذريه من بعدهم
افتهلكنا بما فعل المبطلون
وكذلك نفصل الايات ولعلهم يرجعون
واتل عليهم نبا الذي اتيناه اياتنا فانسلخ
منها فاتبعه الشيطان فكان من الغاوين
ولو شئنا لرفعناه بها ولكنه اخلد الى
الارض واتبعها هواه
فمثله كمثل الكلب ان تحمل عليه ينهث او
تتركه يلهث ذلك مثل القوم الذين كذبوا
باياتنا
فاقصص القصص لعلهم يتفكرون
ساء مثلا القوم الذين كذبوا باياتنا
وانفسهم كانوا يظلمون
من يهدي الله فهو المهتدي ومن يضلل فاولئك
هم الخاسرون
ولقد ذرانا لجهنم كثيرا من الجن والانس
لهم قلوب لا يفقهون بها ولهم اعين لا
يبصرون بها ولهم اذان لا يسمعون بها اولئك
كالانعام بل هم اظن اولئك هم الغافلون
ولله الاسماء الحسنى فادعوه بها وذروا
الذين يلحدون في اسمائه
سيجزون ما كانوا يعملون
وممن خلقنا امه يهدون بالحق وبه يعدلون
والذين كذبوا باياتنا انا سنستدرجهم
من حيث لا يعلمون
واملي لهم ان كيدي متين اولم يتفكروا ما
بصاحبهم من جنه ان هو الا نذير مبين
اولم ينظروا في ملكوت السماوات والارض وما
خلق الله من شيء وان عسى ان يكون قد اقترب
اجلهم فباي حديث
بعده يؤمنون
من يضلل الله فلا هادي له ويذرهم في
طغيانهم يعمهون
يسالونك عن الساعه ايام مرساها قل انما
علمها عند الله لا يجل قل انما علمها عند
ربي لا يجنيها لوقتها الا هو
ثقلت في السماوات والارض لا تاتيكم الا
بغته يسالونك كانك حفي عنها قل انما علمها
عند الله ولكن اكثر الناس لا يعلمون
قل انما علمها عند الله ولكن اكثر الناس
لا يعلمون
قل لا املك لنفسي نفعا ولا ضرا الا ما شاء
الله
ولو كنت اعلم الغيب لاستكثرت من الخير وما
مسني السوء
ان انا الا نذير وبشير لقوم يؤمنون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
هو الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده وجعل منها
زوجها ليسكن اليها فلما تغشاها حملت حملا
خفيفا فمضت به فلما اثقلت الدعو الله
ربهما لئن اتيتنا صالحا لنكونن من
الشاكرين
فلما اتاهما صالحا جعل له شركاء فيما
اتاهما
فتعالى الله عما يشركون
ايشركون ما يخلق شيئا وهم يخلقون
ولا يستطيعون لهم نصرا ولا انفسهم ينصرون
وان تدعوهم الى الهدى لا يتبعوكم
سواء عليكم ادعوتموهم ام انتم صامتون
ان الذين تدعون من دون الله عباد امثالكم
فادعوهم فليستجيبوا لكم ان كنتم صادقين
الهم ارجل يمشون بها ام لهم ايدي يبطشون
بها ام لهم اعين يبصرون بها ام لهم اذان
يسمعون بها
قل ادعوا شركاءكم
ثم كيدوني فلا تنظرون
ان وليي الله الذي نزل الكتاب وهو يتولى
الصالحين
والذين تدعون من
لا يستطيعون نصركم ولا انفسهم ينصرون
وان تدعوهم الى الهدى لا يسمعوا وتراهم
ينظرون اليك وهم لا يبصرون
خذ العفو وامر بالعرف واعرض عن الجاهلين
واما ينزغنك
من الشيطان نز غ فاستعث بالله
انه سميع عليم ان الذين اتقوا اذا مسهم
طائف
من الشيطان تذكروا فاذا هم مبصرون
واخوانهم يمدونهم في الغي ثم لا يقصرون
واذا لم تاتهم بايه قالوا لولا اجتبيتها
قل انما اتبع ما يوحى الي من ربي هذا
بصائر من ربكم وهدى ورحمه لقوم يؤمنون
واذا قرئ القران فاستمعوا له وانصتوا
لعلكم ترحمون
واذكر ربك في نفسك تضرعا وخيفه ودون الجهر
من القول بالغدو والاصال
من القول بالغدو والاصال ولا تكن من
الغافلين
ان الذين عند ربك لا يستكبرون عن عبادته
ويسبحونه
وله يسجدون
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يسالونك عن
الانثال قل الامثال لله والرسول فاتقوا
الله واصلحوا ذات بينكم واطيعوا الله
ورسوله ان كنتم مؤمنين
انما المؤمنون الذين اذا ذكر الله وجلت
قلوبهم واذا تليت عليهم اياته زادتهم
ايمانا وعلى ربهم يتوكلون
الذين يقيمون الصلاه ومما رزقناهم ينفقون
اولئك هم المؤمنون حقا
لهم درجات عند ربهم ومغفره
ورزق كريم
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
كما اخرجك ربك من بيتك بالحق وان فريقا من
المؤمنين لكارهون
يجادلونك في الحق بعدما تبينك انما يساقون
الى الموت وهم ينظرون
واذ يعدكم الله احدى الطائفتين
انها لكم وتودون ان غير ذات الشوكه تكون
لكم ويريد الله ان يحق الحق بكلماته ويقطع
دابر الكافرين
ليحق الحق ويبطل الباطل ولو كره المجرمون
اذ اذ تستغيثون ربكم فاستجاب لكم اني
ممدكم بالف من الملائكه مردفين
وما جعله الله الا بشرى ولتطمئن
به قلوبكم وما النصر الا من عند الله
ان الله عزيز حكيم
اذ يغشيكم النعاس امنه منه وينزل عليكم من
السماء ماء ماء ليطهركم به
وينزل عليكم من السماء ماء
ليطهركم به ويذهب عنكم رجز الشيطان وليربط
على قلوبكم ويثبت به الاقدام
اذ يوحي ربك الى الملائكه
اني معكم فثبتوا الذين امنوا سالقي في
قلوب الذين كفروا الرعب فاضربوا فوق
الاعناق واضربوا منهم كل بنان
ذلك بانهم شاقوا
الله ورسوله ومن يشاق الله ورسوله فان
الله شديد العقاب
ذلكم فذوقوه وان للكافرين عذابا
النار
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا لقيتم الذين
كفروا زحفا فلا تولوهم الادبار
ومن يولهم يومئذ دبره الا متحرفا لقتال او
متحيزا الى فئه فقد باء
فقد باء بغضب من الله وماواه جهنم وبئس
المصير
فلم تقتلوهم ولكن الله قتلهم وما رميت اذ
رميت ولكن الله رمى وليبلي المؤمنين منه
بلاء
حسنا ان الله سميع عليم ذلكم وان الله
موهن كيد الكافرين
ان تستفتحوا فقد جاءكم
الفتح وان تنتهوا فهو خير لكم وان تعودوا
نعد ولن تغني ولن تغني عنكم فئتكم شيئا
ولو كثرت وان الله مع المؤمنين
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك اياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله والرسول
ولا تولوا عنه وانتم تسمعون
يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله ورسوله
ولا تكونوا كالذين قالوا سمعنا وهم لا
يسمعون
ان شر الدواب
عند الله الصم البكم الذين لا يعقلون
ولو علم الله فيهم خيرا لاسمعهم ولو
اسمعهم لتولوا وهم معرضون
يا ايها الذين امنوا استجيبوا لله وللرسول
اذا دعاكم لما يحييكم
واعلموا ان الله يحول بين المرء وقلبه
وانه اليه تحشرون
واتقوا فتنه لا تصيبن
الذين ظلموا منكم خاصه
واعلموا ان الله شديد العقاب
واذكروا اذ انتم قليل مستضعفون في الارض
تخافون ان يتخطفكم الناس فاواكم وايدكم
بنصر نصره فاواكم وايدكم بنصره ورزقكم من
الطيبات لعلكم تشكرون
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تخونوا الله
والرسول وتخوا اماناتكم وانتم تعلمون
واعلموا انما اموالكم واولادكم فتنه وان
الله عنده اجر عظيم عظيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تتقوا الله يجعل
لكم فرقانا ويكفر عنكم سيئاتكم ويغفر لكم
والله ذو الفضل العظيم
واذ يمكر بك الذين كفروا ليثبتوك او
يقتلوك او يخرجوك ويمكرون ويمكر الله
والله خير الماكرين
واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا قالوا قد سمعنا لو
نشاء لقلنا مثل هذا ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين
واذ قالوا اللهم ان كان هذا هو الحق من
عندك فامطر علينا حجاره من السماء
او ائتنا بعذاب اليم
وما كان الله ليعذبهم وانت فيهم وما كان
الله معذبهم وهم يستغفرون
وما لهم الا يعذبهم الله وهم يصدون عن
المسجد الحرام وما كانوا اولياءه
ان اولياؤه
الا المتقون ولكن اكثرهم لا يعلمون
وما كان صلاتهم عند البيت الا مكاء
وتصديه
فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم تكفرون
ان الذين كفروا ينفقون اموالهم ليصدوا عن
سبيل الله
فسينفقونها
ثم تكون عليهم حسره ثم يغلبون والذين
كفروا الى جهنم يحشرون
ليميز الله الخبيث من الطيب ويجعل الخبيث
بعضه على بعض فيركمه جميعا فيجعله في جهنم
اولئك هم الخاسرون
قل للذين كفروا ان ينتهوا يغفر لهم ما قد
سلف وان يعودوا فقد مضت سنه الاولين
وقاتلوهم حتى لا تكون فتنه ويكون الدين
كله لله
فانوا فان الله بما يعملون بصير
وان تولوا فاعلموا ان الله مولاكم
نعم المولى ونعم النصير
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ركعه
الله
اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى
سبحان ربي الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى
والذي
اخرج المر عاه فجعله غثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى
الا ما شاء الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى
وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره
خير وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم رحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قل يا
ايها الكافرون
لا
اعبد ما تعبدون
ولا
انتم عابدون ما
اعبد
ولا
انا عابد ما عبدتم
انتم عابدون ما
اعبد
لكم دينكم ولي دين
الله
اكبر سبحان
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر سبحان
[Arabic recitation]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له
كفوا احد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
قل اعوذ برب الفلق من شر ما خلق ومن شر
غاسق اذا وقب ومن شر
النفاثات
في العقد ومن شر حاسد اذا حسد بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
قل اعوذ برب الناس
ملك الناس
اله
الناس
من شر الوسواس خناس
الذي يوسوس في صدور
الناس
من الجنه
والناس
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
كثيرا مباركا فيه من السماوات ومن العظيم
ومن ما بينهما ومنا ما شئت من شيء اللهم
اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
الله
اكبر
سبحان الله
التحيات ايها
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
الحمد
‏number